les échos du festival d'avignon avec ce
soir l'un des spectacles phares du cru
91 la tempête
monté par peter brook spectacle phare
pour au moins deux raisons
le nom du metteur en scène et le lieu où
il est donné
reportage de dominique poncet et
jean-jacques le deuil avec quelle fibre
et hissé le rêve avec quel rêve est
fabriqué la réalité ce sont pour ces
deux interrogations supporter ou qu'elle
choisit de monter la tempête
l'oeuvre testamentaire de liliane 6 me
une pièce qui se déroule bien au-delà
des frontières du vraisemblable est une
pièce comme tout le le shakespeare
fondement ce que le tueur c'est à dire
c'est une quête métaphysique de ces mots
et on essaie de trouver dans shakespeare
tout autre chose alors je constatais que
quand un acteur vous dans une ville
aujourd'hui à une agression ce clown en
nationaliste
obligatoirement même si en lui une
planche son intuition spirituelle qui a
nagé tous les hommes pleins par rapport
au sauna d'écouté immense de trouver les
formes juste celui qui né et éduqué dans
les formes traditionnelles ou la rupture
entre le monde invisible et le monde dit
nathan qu'on était fait
un accès plus direct aux sources
d'où viennent les images et les actions
de la complète
c'est pour cela que travers des acteurs
badiner japonais et à pékin
une certaine réalité la pièce peut
apparaître la tempête montée magnifié
par peter brook dans un lieu magique
découvert par lui un cirque de sable et
de pierres d'une extraordinaire beauté
naturelle dernière information